[Musique]
ils passent en moyenne de 0 à 120
km/heure en trois secondes ces drones
sont programmés pour la course des
p'tits bolides volant à quatre hélices
télécommande est piloté grâce à un
casque connecté à une caméra descend
pour justement pour le parking le plus
grand plus de puissance et donc là je
vais régler de façon à avoir vraiment un
répit de tabouk dans la dans la
trajectoire et la caméra donc réglé une
luminosité puisqu'on est là partout c on
a une force en parking du tout c'est un
endroit très confiné et donc du coup au
niveau espace pour la chine qui ne soit
pas trop puissante pour éviter de taper
le plafond s'est passé se passe plutôt
bien je n'ai pas tapé mais sarah stress
plutôt bien un circuit lumineux dans le
sous sol de l'école d'ingénieurs de
montigny le bretonneux cette troisième
édition de la course de drones a
rassemblé 15 pilotes
organisé par l'association estac à
modélisme
[Musique]
bonjour le parking dans le noir et nos
balises ont le circuit à l'aide à l'aide
de l'aide
justement est ce qui permet vraiment aux
pilotes d'avoir un circuit assez
atypique et et ce qui suscite leur
curiosité
cette course entre dans le calendrier de
l'association avec comme objectif de
démocratiser cette pratique sportive
naissante
[Musique]